pleased to welcome you back to the to
the last panel of what has really been I
must say a most engaging conference
tonight and I thank you all very much
for being here and and and I I am I deal
in copyright issues so naturally my my
ears perked up every time I heard the
word copyright mention quoting from the
Constitution saying anything about
patents all of that you know just sort
of sort of got got me a buzz unto them
to agree and and and anna and i can't i
can't help but paraphrase one of the
really important questions that came up
earlier in the day and that is what
would it take to convince you to set
aside some of your funding to address
these intellectual property issues that
are part of the data management data
creation process so and i say that
because of one thing and that is that
lawyers are your friend and it's very
very important to keep that in mind so
so with that said i am happy and
delighted I'm honored to to to to
moderate this panel and to to introduce
our speakers you have their biographies
will go in a slightly different order
for different reasons but I'm gerhard
Klimek from purdue will be first
followed by micha Altman from from MIT
and then mark hun L from from fig share
and then 10th Dennis tenon my colleague
here at Columbia will do the response
and so please Gerard
so what I'd like to share some of the
excitement we see in nano hub it has
very little to do with data but but just
bear with me and just for for 10 minutes
and it might be relevant to you so what
you see here on the screen is actually
usage on a website called nano org in
February of last year and you see green
spikes those are people signing up for a
site the bigger the symbol or more
people show up at a particular time they
turn into yellow dots that run
simulations and then there's a whole
bunch of red dots that look at seminars
lectures and tutorials so when I thought
I get this prepared I would have thought
there's a sine wave of activity running
through the globe but apparently nano
scientists really don't sleep and and it
shows it's really a global service that
is provided to do for the rest of the
world I try to describe that there is
knowledge transfer happening in that
site and so that's one part of the topic
and I highlight some items and then I
talk about myth-busting I'm going to
talk about all these things we were told
we couldn't do because they're so hard
and nobody has really succeeded one way
to look at this data is also in a static
image so here the users in 2012
superposed on NASA at night so basically
we keep people up at night all over the
world where there is civilization that
lights up the sky more or less so so
that's a pretty global impact and you
might ask yourself what are these people
are doing and why are they coming and
what are the incentives for all of this
so if you take nothing away from this
talk but these this one slide I'll be
very happy you must need meet all the
needs for all stakeholders that means
you have to look at the developers think
of them as providers of products now
scientists don't like to be called
providers of deliverable and have
deliverables right they will get really
upset but it just be with me for a
minute then you have to have a method
that is accessible you have to have a
market and you have to have users or
consumers on all of that of that market
and all three
of these entities have completely
different requirements and if you don't
meet them you have a good dream but if
you really want to make this work you
got to meet the requirements of all of
these three classes of stakeholders so
that's what I want to talk about so we
had web forms for a while since about
nineteen ninety-six and we changed
something and we rose up a little bit
with growth once we made applications
interactive I'll show you a little bit
of what we mean by that we there's a lot
of talk about MOOCs these days we
started to put lectures and courses on
the web we have over 250 thousand users
annually now so so there apparently
there is a need and there's users that
come to that and let's figure out what
they all do we had our own little stock
market crash so well one key message is
all free it's actually provided by NSF
but really we don't take your credit
card or anything so in there's many
signs gateways out there and there's
also then a lot of myths out there where
users think that you cannot use research
codes for education you've got to write
your own custom apps for that and
certainly you can't use somebody else's
code for your own research and
experimental asst will never touch that
the developers things building a user
interface is way too difficult I don't
have time for that I must rewrite my
code in order to put it on the web I
don't have time for that and by the way
why should I bother because i can write
papers myself thank you very much and
certainly there was no end to end
science cloud that was really accessible
so so you again you have to think of
these as customers you have to think of
this as a market and you have to think
of it as suppliers and if you can make
them all ends meet then you have
something so here's a little overview so
imagine the other side where you can
access tools rather readily out of a
list you can launch them it all runs in
a web browser these are tools that are
interactive they're sort of documented
where you can hover over items by the
way this is a tool that was generated by
an undergrad in my lab in about a week
and you didn't even know what a carbon
nanotube is well here you can visualize
the density of states of a carbon
we can hover over data you can compare
nanotubes like this you can do all of
that interactively you don't do that
just for one tool you do that for many
tools in fact we have 260 of these tools
now here's a tool that visualizes a nano
biopore thats how ions flow through a
poor this is a tool that was built
originally at texas instruments where i
used to be then there's a the next
there's a tool where we build or model
artificial atoms so here's an S orbital
and a so called quantum dot there's a
p-orbital you can compare them you can
do all kinds of things these are not
little gimmick applications these are
scientific application that might have
taken years upon years to write and they
might run on a cloud base they might run
in a grid computing days completely
transparent to the end user because
really they don't care they really want
to just look at data examine data or
examine tools and models all right so
then there's a whole environment where
you can ask questions and there's you
can earn a nose for for contributing you
can spend nanos on a coffee cup or on
better services so let me just step out
of the videos so you might think of a
tool that looks like this where you
can't read what it really means you'd
have to study it for a month before you
write your own input deck that would be
a traditional industrial type tool you
can then do fancy visualizations compare
data we can do that but we can do one
better we can actually wrap this same
tool and make it a little bit simpler so
actually undergrads can design what we
call a MOSFET the field effect
transistor that runs in any of your
computers and we do that for a couple of
tools and suddenly these tools become
really usable and we have six thousand
users on a tool or on apps that are
wrapped around a real tool and the real
gigs really want to run this still here
but we have a whole lot more users that
are out there that run the simple app so
user interfaces absolutely critical and
when I mentioned we had web forms this
is sort of what your bank has today you
fill out some numbers click query and
you get something you can't do anything
with write a static gif image you can't
do anything really with we had that for
a while with some classroom spikes but
these guys never came back right
change that to an interactive tool like
that and we saw a little bit of growth
right that's kind of nice but what's
even more compelling is this code is
actually an open source code and we
track the downloads and suddenly the
downloads of this code also drop so it's
actually a not anti correlation between
usability on the web and a need to
install your dang code yourself because
he likes to install codes thank you oh
sorry the one oddball you can still
download it that's all right so so now
but that is not unusual right we all
balance usability versus capability
remember the days when the iphone came
out people said what what is that right
it care there's more fancy phones out
there for years or ipad right there's
computers like that for many years but
they weren't usable right and they
change our world because these things
actually become usable not that they
were out there before it's not being
about being first it's about being
usable right and we know this on a
day-to-day basis so what's the normal
process to put stuff in the web it's
like this a proposal says I got a cool
code I'm going to hire a web developer
the web develop speaks a different
language and it takes this guy over here
about two to three years to build a tool
that shows up on the web two to three
years 500k all right which researcher do
you know that sits on there but for
three years and doesn't do anything that
to their code great no hands right
doesn't exist this guy builds new
versions of tools in those two to three
years that means that person will never
ever touch the stuff that's on the web
ever so there's no point in doing it
because this person here would be the
ideal person to test this right so it's
broken it's by default already broken so
and if you wanted to do this at 500 k /
tool and you want to put 88 tools on the
web that would be 88 million dollars oh
sorry hundred seventy-five tools and
four years 88 million dollars I can
guarantee you NSF does not give us that
kind of money so we do something that's
very different and we try to overcome
what the users now think right the users
think well these are toy tools right
they're not real tools they're just
gimmicks right
or so they are not real research codes
and can't do real research and maybe I
can use it for education so we there's
actually a bad reputation on science
gateways out there alright so what we do
is we actually eliminate this middleman
we got rid of this person and we did
publish hundred seventy five tools in
four years alright and we do that in one
to two weeks that means we put this guy
the supplier he doesn't want to be a
supplier back in power we don't disown
them from his own product and they can
put this online in one to two weeks now
that's quite powerful because we give
them a whole infrastructure where they
can do that a whole framework workspaces
repository git repository access to
grids staging and testing and then a
publication platform and then the tools
get published with a DOI that's a whole
framework and one way you can think of
that is that's the new machine shop for
the next next generation of developers
right and this really works and i want
to show you that it works with numbers
so here number of tools in blue number
of developers in green so we are 260
tools some foreigner developers as of
today and these i said these stella
bella purrs built new versions right and
they do we have 1400 new versions of
these codes on the web active you can
think of this as suppliers products and
product innovation so these data sets /
tools actually evolve they're no longer
the static tarball zip file that hangs
out there it actually gets supported and
it develops right there's not an
assumption of perfectness it actually
evolves or so the supply chain maybe
works so now what are the market
incentives to drive people there all
right so we can make charts of
collaborators versus number of users
served right so on a log-log scale if
you have a lot of collaborators you
actually serve a lot of users you can
call that your supplier Network right if
you have the suppliers network with each
other they can actually have powerful
products let's look at one of those
developers former postdoc in my group
created some 6008 tools with six
thousand users that are using that every
provider gets in a sense a chart like
that looks really good on an NSF
proposal when you say I'm going to have
an outreach program because
that person has one quantitatively so he
left went to Southern Illinois suddenly
usage at that site spikes up
dramatically he infuses it into his own
classroom he builds new classes he uses
it for research he gets promoted after
two years that's not bad especially if
the if his department had says it's
actually his involvement with non hub in
the leverage is actually good so there's
somewhat of an incentive system actually
change ways all right so now we have 260
products apparently it can be done the
myth busted now the question is what are
these people doing so here is this
marketplace right apparently we're
accessible let's not argue about that so
now the customers out here the question
is what are they doing because remember
you can't use such thing for education
because these are research tools and by
the way you can use it for research
because you have to write your own tools
right so how do we measure that we have
our own matrix so we have to look into
the matrix now we actually look at the
behavior of people because you can't see
we cluster our user by behavior they say
show up on a Tuesday all come for a
homework assignment or they come
throughout the whole semester and use
one tool throughout a whole semester and
here's a break it's called spring break
and then there's one they use one two
three four or five different tools
throughout the whole semester we can
actually positively identify what these
groups are I can tell you where they are
at be in violation of some laws but
basically sophomores seniors freshmen
and chemistry graduates and electrical
engineering software Mars and mechanical
engineering so a lot of people we can
actually identify these guys that look
completely erratic they are not
correlated with experimental researchers
computational researchers and there's a
group we know nothing about all right so
to give you a feeling we can do all
kinds of things basically we can
identify 14,000 students in some 800
classes at 180 institutions that
systematically use this site for
education which they can't do right
because that's impossible to do and
these are research codes they're not
custom codes for education all right I
think that's a possibility
now the really cool thing is since
everything has a DOI of these tools we
can sort of measure the time to market
or the first time adoption in the
classroom so how long do you think it
takes for a tool to be adopted compare
that to say four years of a textbook
development ballpark from one edition
well I can put this the histogram of it
we have 19 tools that were adopted
within a week in the classroom about 22
adopted within the month 31 adopted
within three months overall half of the
tools are adopted with a less than half
a year that's a pretty fast
time-to-market to actually influence how
you do education after you discovered
something in research so now remember
you can't do research right so now
here's an electrical engineer that draw
a social network chart 960 papers each
dot is a paper in the literature citing
nano up apparently you can do research
there's people that might use us as a
benchmark here's one paper I'm going to
skim through they use as a benchmark
build their own tools said compare their
own tool against the one that's on
nanohub but the problem is where's the
data so that's where we're going to go
next we want to have and keep that data
and actually link it in the in the
publication and go back to that data
experimentalists they actually use us
these are the color coding for
experimentalist about thirty percent of
the papers involve experimental data is
a really cool example publication in
March of 11 using a tool that was
published in april of 10 alright less
than 11 months of publishing a new tool
an experimental group picking it up that
has nothing to do with it and using it
and by the way that group has nothing to
do with us we've become a publication
venue alright and then they do data and
where is the data that's where we're
going to go next I don't have to explain
h-index to this because the first thing
I after I showed the social network
charts for years ago they said well okay
yeah you can do research but is it good
right so now we're going to measure the
secondary citations secondary citation
index we had 45 apparently it's not bad
research either the point is you can't
dis an axis of teaching worse and axes
of research you shouldn't separate
research and education tools actually
span balls let's keep that
you can now set what that means later so
we apparently are usable across the
globe and we are transferable we are
actually now not spawn on half 0 and out
of nano hub we're powering some 40 hubs
and I don't have time that we actually
have some data hubs now that embrace
data and actually made data useful
that's not a nano thing so it's one of
my team members work but the key is it's
all about usability if you are useful
with the data that you so desperately
like to host make them usable you will
find users that will pay for it and make
an occult in the economy around it and
then it's a workable thing thank you so
Gerard if you don't mind my asking how
did you deal with the copyright and
other issues in the soft in the new
software that they've created so every
piece of software has to have a license
so that we can take it and hows it but
most of the software actually is not
open source it's open access so what we
provide is a venue to see the executable
and a user interface but in general
unless it's a declared open source code
people don't get access to the code and
those yep I'm sorry and so he said among
the for example graduate students who
develop the software they are those
students presumably they still own the
rights and they have given a very broad
license and open access license that's
exactly right we don't we don't disown
people and we don't impose a license
about ten percent of the codes are open
source because because people want to do
that but we don't enforce it okay so you
offer up a roster of choices open access
open source and maybe even others in
connection with it and
shading the difference open source
really in in in common terms you're
giving it away so that the community of
anybody who can work with that code may
use it may enhance it may may reapply it
but open access is usability ssion is
usability I can get to it and
reproducible of it but maybe not a lot
more than that or not as much not as
much and you get around a lot of
distracting discussions yeah very good
very happy to introduce Mike Micah
Altman from from MIT
so
I am a social and information scientist
MIT and virtually affiliated with
Brookings all work is collaborative so
number of co-conspirators lots of stuff
on the web if you want to look at more
and the obligatory disclaimer so the
talk is divided up into three pieces one
what's the changing research climate
second how do we maximize impact this
session is supposed to be about impact
so how do we manage that maximize the
impact of research through managing
research data and then doing something
so what's the climate for research well
one word more all right we've got we've
got the the LHC producing terror by a
petabyte of data every every two weeks
when it's up and running 50,000 people
attending courses from you know of
course from you Michigan or Stanford
online for MOOCs 200,000 and more
authors on a data set for the Galaxy Zoo
and instead of my colleagues and
political science instead of fielding
surveys every month with a couple
hundred people to measure social
opinions public opinion we can look at
nine thousand tweets a second so there's
more stuff and there's more of
everything else too and they're also
more recognition of some of the problems
in scholarship that that have been there
but are in some ways emphasized by by
this morn asst one is that unpublished
data ends up in the desk drawer and this
is a literally a bit of data that would
have been unpublished if Daniel sheckman
hadn't insisted for many years that this
aberration in his data was not was not
in fact false and he got the Nobel Prize
for quasi symmetry but after that
happened people there were many lab
notebooks that came out and punk
my find that too bad but the point is
when you when you get to see everyone's
mistakes you can tell a mistake from
there's increasing concern about the
reliability of the scientific record and
also increasing concern about the
erosion of the scientific evidence base
and and by the way compliance there are
many policies that have been issued over
the years to deal with but compliances
as usual an issue so one the set of
observations come out of this one is
that the practice of science the
researchers evidence base and
publications they're shifting and often
this is shifting to the edges another is
that the emphasis on filtering
replication integration and reuse that's
becoming more important relative to
formal publication and at least in some
areas there's an increasing recognition
that that organizations both commercial
and educational and nonprofit are
producing information assets that are
should be durable have durable value and
are worthy of managing well so that's
climate the climate is increasingly
favorable but climate is what you should
expect and weather is what you get and
so there have been shifts in the weather
many favorable weather has this year has
brought us in MOOCs it's brought us in
the white house is open access policy
it's brought in copyright cases Georgia
State it's brought in Amazon glacier and
commercial commercial movement into the
data management space in a serious way
into the long long term access space
and weather will continue to blow both
ways so what what's the theory so in
theory think it's it's useful to
identify what are the goals of the data
management and when you look at various
data management plans and institutions
it's clear that there are different
sorts of goals that are being embodied
in plans that are motivating different
stakeholders and these include at least
one cluster around orchestrating the
value of data to a research group for
specific project I need to have my data
around so i can write my papers do my
analysis if my postdoc leaves the
research shouldn't fall apart so that
that's one one set of objectives for
data management another is well there's
this sensitive stuff it may be stuff
that's protected by IP it may be
sensitive confidence sensitive
information about individuals could be
confidential information from businesses
the sites of locations of endangered
species archaeological digs there's
information that we don't want disclosed
and so parts of data management plans
and parts of data management policies
are focused on this disclosure
limitation aspect and that's that's
another operational goal there's a
there's there's a compliance goal
contracts policies regulations and
there's a dissemination goal and behind
those goals are a set of use-values
right and you need when you're thinking
about data management and maximizing the
impact using it to maximize the impact
of research you need to think about what
what use values different aspects of
your data management are impacting
whether its use by that research team
used by the discipline use by the wider
community use by the public and as we
get be used by the institution as we go
beyond that research team that controls
the data that wrote the grant if you
know one did we get into the problem
public goods or not really public goods
and not really Commons either all right
there in in you know in the classic
framework there were public and private
goods and then Elinor Ostrom and company
came in and he's doubt the commons etc
and so what we have are Kwazii public
goods information is non dimensional and
sort of partially excludable depending
on whether it's software which you can
sort of keep people out preserved data
which may be you can license or just
best practices which somehow get
everywhere or at least they they don't
really get everywhere but they they they
could to anyone who wants them and what
we know about quazy public data or quasi
public goods is that they're under
provisioned it by pure markets at a pure
market approach never gives you the
socially right amount of non private
goods and so it's we shouldn't expect
this a data either so and ostrom has
done a lot of Nobel prize-winning work
on characterizing what affects Kwazii
public goods Commons and other things in
that area whether the and and one of the
the sets of characteristics one should
look for our accent situations
stakeholders legal and institutional
constraints and norms and values all of
these are important in successfully
managing non private goods for some sort
of social optum so one one area to look
at that we've spent a lot of time as the
information lifecycle it's important not
just to look at one stage there are
stakeholders at each stage of the
information like light pole different
and different actors care start to care
at different stages which means that if
you only focus on one or the incentives
of one you're going to forget about the
stakeholders they're not and you're
going to be in trouble because they'll
come in later if you don't catch a
caption that the earlier stages and
there are a number of legal
strengths there are access rights there
are contracts there are intellectual
property rights and then there are
confidentiality restrictions and the
confidentiality restrictions even the
u.s. there are approximately two
thousand plus laws that affect data
privacy RIT largely including if you
include things like wiretapping laws in
50 states and there are different
variations oral these apply to oral
recordings for research possibly and and
all of the others data management norms
some of the norms that appear important
for successful management our
information stewardship awareness of the
information lifecycle awareness beyond
institutional boundaries and beyond
disciplinary boundaries much of the
value of data management that we're
talking about is a social in public
sense is the value either to the
institution that produced it or the
public value and this often means that
the value is captured much later and
through reuse maybe in a different
discipline and we're trust norms only
work where there's some level of trust
right and there is a this is a huge
community and so there needs to be
engineering approaches in place so that
that trust can be demonstrated and
justified
though there are a number of operational
aspects actually those have been mapped
out reasonably well and there are lots
of checklists and we could go into
detail which we won't but I think the
more important part to look at when
you're looking at data management is
what are the requirements for a
community information infrastructure and
we've started to tease out some of these
roughly incentives dissemination access
control provenance persistence legal
protections usability economic models
trust models there's a lot there's a lot
going on there so observations
critically important to develop coherent
empirically based economic models for
valuing stuff this is one of the big
gaps how do you what's the net present
present value expected value of your big
data set how do you diversify across
your data collections to to maximize the
future production of knowledge and
optimal management is going to require
looking in all these different aspects
stakeholders information norms etc so
practice you got to do something that's
all theory there are many emerging tools
not so many solutions most of the tools
are coming from disciplines and
disciplines often need to do something
which so that's that's a you know good
driver the critical gaps that I've seen
in practice are around research
identifiers citation practices
reproducibility stewardship compliance
information privacy and all of that
other stuff that we have to deal with so
there are some shameless plugs for
projects that I'm actually involved in
in one way or another that address start
to address some of these issues you
should pour over those and follow all
the links and look at them later over it
be with just the main idea is that if
you keep all your data in one place or
even in one institution there you can't
protect it from all of the likely forms
of risks so you need to spread your
data across multiple institutions but
then you gotta trust them you're going
to trust them to do what they say or not
have the capacity to do what they say so
how how do we strengthen that trust and
there have been a number of approaches
in this community and we've one of the
research approaches we focused on is
auditing auditing distributive
preservation networks to with the prop
with the product called safe archive to
see that they match up to high human
level preservation policies if you say
you got three copies and they're in this
region they're updated how do we know
can you prove it can you prove it
externally without letting us look at
the data and we built some stuff and it
turns out that distributed distributing
your replication your preservation
across institutions is absolutely
necessary for for avoiding these risks
and it also so it's it also makes it a
lot more difficult to figure out what's
where your data is and and the
assumptions the single point of failure
is gone that's the good thing that's the
point but all of those background
assumptions that you collected the data
the copies at the same time and you
follow the same procedures and that
you're speaking the same that you
speaking you have the same metadata
standards etc all those things go out
the window and so when you see for
example that two copies and you're
different institutions are the same that
may not may be that the collections find
it may be that the the software system
you use to ingest those things broke in
the same way we've seen that right when
you see that they're different it may be
that the replications are bad or it may
be that your provider is delivering
institutionally customized front pages
on your journal articles so that the
intellectual content in both
institutions is the same but the bits
are different and these are things that
you need to deal with in a distributed
environment so distributed digital
preservation works but you need to tune
it through evidence
auditing so last slide 70 solicited
advice I have the luxury of being a
researcher in a library and I think in a
changing environment any operational
problem has the chance of becoming a
plied research problem and so one should
aspire to open scalable solutions that
meet the state of the art and practice
scalable solutions are going to eat your
lunch if you do don't and but you need
to expect to do prototypes experiments
rapid iterations and yeah trust other
institutions but verify that their don't
relation
I just want to first of all say thank
you to everybody hanging around because
it's like a day of information overload
and to see so many people still here is
really good and thanks for everybody for
using the hashtag and tweeting because
to see that other people are tweeting
about this conference from all over the
world really shows that the conference
is having an impact and that's what this
session is about so a little fun but I'm
going to be talking about picture so for
those of you who don't know what fig
share is it's a platform where any
researcher can make anybody can make any
research output sizable shareable and
discoverable so just from a personal
note this is where I came from I I was a
researcher and I came up from that
aspect i had i was doing my PhD in the
life sciences in stem cell biology and i
had a lot of videos a lot of data sets
and those were my those were my research
outputs and at the moment the
dissemination of research content that
we have doesn't really help you if
you've got videos and data sets I can
tell you now that a year after finishing
my PhD I have three papers out they have
five static images in them and that
doesn't really tell the whole story
about what my research was so as I say I
decided naively it'd be much easier to
just set up but a platform where you
could make all of your research outputs
discoverable shareable in sizable and
this is a stock fig share slide so it
was awesome that this session is
actually called discover share an impact
because we're pretty much on the nail
there but the only other thing that we
don't have is impact we've say sizeable
because we're catering to the needs of
researchers and a lot of them don't
understand that there they have anything
they can have an impact that isn't
citations but we do get our site or D
everything is sizeable with a DOI we get
our do eyes from data site at the
California digital library if anybody
needs some identifiers I highly
recommend working with joining the team
at the California digital library
because they are also awesome hmm and
now related to that I'm going to have my
one humble brag of the talk which is so
we're talking about impact which is the
one thing we're not looking at there and
data site put out there most accessed oh
well actually even more than that is a
discoverability so data site put out
there mo
accessed do is in January of the
originally was a top 10 but they found
another one and fixture was eight of the
top ten so we're proving we can be quite
discoverable and just an example of what
that looks like this was the number one
most access do I through data site in
the in January and you can see it's
something that went online in I don't
know if this worked no I shouldn't have
pushed that eject but you can see the
this has had nearly 10,000 views it went
online in December and you say well
10,000 views it's had 60 shares we make
everything shareable via different
social networks and we track these
metrics so 60 shares so shareable we've
added that little content there but is
this true impact you know can all this
altmetrics that Heather was talking
about is that really impact well this is
also as I say it came out in December
this is this object research output has
already been cited in nature everything
gets sizable with the DOI we say here's
how you cite this you can export it to
ref man n no Mandalay we just want to
make it really easy because at the
moment we're saying why would you want
to share your research output so unless
you're someone like me who has a big ego
and wants to make all of the get credit
for everything so suddenly does that
click well maybe every academic has a
bit of a nikka so if you can if you can
give them credit for their research in
that way so if you can give their
metrics if you click on this author's
name on the right there you will get
their cumulative metrics for every
research output they've shared so if
they've had 10,000 views for this they
think well if I share another one I'll
have 20,000 views and things like this
and it's just playing into that mindset
of the academic there so as I said the
name is quite confusing fig share we for
originally for me so I had a lot of
negative data that wasn't going to get
published anywhere so I had all these
figures that weren't going to get
published but I did that for a reason it
was you know I looked at these cells and
I added this chemical and was looking at
receptors to see if the levels went up
or down and there was no change but I
did that for a reason I thought that my
hypothesis was there was going to be a
change if I'm doing it particularly in
stem cells which is massively fun
at the moment then somebody else is
going to be doing the same experiment
somewhere but you're never going to
write a paper about all your negative
data who's going to waste three days to
hang up a paper so I thought if you can
just do something that you know makes it
very easy to share this data much that
you'd share a video on youtube or a you
know images on flickr because
dissemination of content on the internet
has been fixed people have done this you
know you can share videos you can share
images you can share code so why are we
inventing all these odd-looking
repositories when we can just copy the
systems that have proven successful so
that's what we've tried to do one of the
things we do which was what I wanted was
to visualize the content in the browser
because not everybody will have that
different types of software not everyone
has excel you know so if you visualize
it in the browser if you visualize the
data set you could play around with it
in the browser and see if you want to
download it beforehand and this is just
some of the formula formats that we
visualize in the browser obviously
there's constantly moving goal post
because academics just invent their own
file formats but as opposed to everybody
in the world trying to every publisher
trying to deal with this we're trying to
deal with it ourselves and then they
don't have to reinvent the wheel so
that's what we're doing in terms of you
know we try to disease good government
pushes at the moment but we're trying to
incentivize people to integrate it into
their workflow to make this sharing of
data a normal thing and you don't even
have to think about doing so two ways in
which we're doing that is working with
publishers and institutions I'll focus
more on the publishers so Linda was
talking about the problems with
supplemental information before we have
just gone plaws which was built on the
internet and it's fantastic public
library of science they open till a week
ago their supplemental data was just a
list of the files and you had to if it
was a video you clicked it you
downloaded it and then you have to hope
you had the right codecs to play that
video which as I say you know the
internet works for these things we can
do this so we now host all of the
supplemental data for applause we make
everything visualize well in the browser
seventy percent of their articles have
supplemental data and if it's a video
you just push play it's like a little
slider you can see everything all the
supplemental data and see the real
things that might want to be in the
article on that note we're working with
faculty of a thousand research where the
actual data if if figure 1 is a data set
then we make a figure 1 the data set
it's all the journal is online so you
don't need to make a screenshot of a
data set it's a data set that you can
play around with if it's video the video
is there is if file set with 50 files in
you can just click through them and so
my favorite my favorite paper that's
come out of that so far is something
that I always wanted with this they have
graphs other figures if you click the
figures the data behind the graph pops
up which is really cool I think that's
just me personally and as I say elsevier
have done this before they they've had
some problems with with their article of
the future when repositories will close
down and that is a problem so we're
trying to be a central repository where
they you don't have to work with 15
different repositories as a publisher
you can just work with one this is an
example of the supplemental data on
plaza should have clicked on a minute
ago as I say that's that's just that
what the supplemental data looks like
you know but a spreadsheet data is hard
to fit into a sub info section on the
paper so we have this overlay that will
pop it up and you can play around with
the data all the macros are enabled and
stuff like this so with regards to
institutions we we do things for the
individual researchers it's all free for
individual researchers you can upload
stuff you keep it private and you choose
to make it publicly available there's as
i said we track the metrics so the way
we incentivize users to share their
research data is to give them things
like badges which dynamically show you
how many views and shares and what have
you've had a view research so people put
these on their blog we see people
tweeting all the time i've just gone
past 10,000 views on fig sure we have a
desktop uploader which is you know the
end of the day you can just drag all
your files in much like Dropbox it
stores more privately you can add some
metadata and choose to make them
publicly available we have an API so
this is really where I think we need to
get to you if you make up we're at the
stage now where it should be become not
should I share my data but where
should I share my data once we get to
that stage that's where the really cool
stuff happens and we pick show you
through the API you can say give me
every bit of spreadsheet data with these
tags in this category in the last six
months pull it all out hope to do some
crunching and really build on the
research that other people have done
before and as I say we're working with
institutions now to provide
institutional fig share accounts so that
they can manage all of their research
data privately in the cloud and access
it from anywhere so if anyone wants to
talk about that second shameless plug
and so the impact of things we heard
Heather talking about impact story
there's also altmetric and plum
analytics the problem here is i said we
make things sizable and people like the
idea that things are sizable they're not
getting around to the idea yet that
there are other metrics you know we
track view shares downloads and things
like this place is like impact story
altmetric and plum analytics they're
doing this on a much bigger scale fig
share is on all three of those and you
can track the details in much more data
much you can see what's happening a lot
better but the funders aren't really
tracking this at the moment whereas they
are saying we should be making research
data available they're not really
looking at the impact side of things as
much as they should so please encourage
them to do this and so this is kind of
the unknown section for me I have a few
questions that I was going to mention
just in terms of you know cuz this is a
panel might as well have some questions
so you know the Thomson Reuters are
doing a data citation index that's going
to start tracking these things which is
really interesting because web of
science and the you know I've just been
talking about different all metrics do
we really want to go back to that one
measure of impact for data sets well I
mean they are tracking fig share data
sets so they're more than welcome to do
that whether that'll be the future of
where this goes I don't know I'd love to
hear people's opinions same with I've
just heard about the elsevier new tools
so I'm really interested to hear where
this goes they said all the data is
going to be open as a priority and
that's really great one thing that I
think has a lot of potential we've had
mentioned before is orchid so if you're
looking at the impact of a researcher
orchid is basically an ID for a
researcher a prison number for a
researcher that everything is connected
to them and so you could use that to
start tracking people and seeing what
their true impact of all of their
researches and we're integrated with
that so we're looking forward to see
where that goes and then the last thing
I wanted to mention was just this you
know the US government has announced
last week the UK is actually ahead of on
this front in that we make we're already
making all of our stuff open access
which is great winning it something but
um the the the US the US will catches it
no time with this one of the interesting
things I wanted to ask everybody here is
eventually I talked to a few people
about this last night they say that all
of the papers have to be open access
they don't really say what the embargo
period has to be on data so they treat
it completely separately still in the in
the release that they gave so I think we
should push them to see what are they
going to do on the data sharing side of
things the impact side of things how are
we going to manage that and are we going
to start tracking these new metrics and
the last thing I wanted to say was how
are we going to start educating the
masses about what they can do on my I
think everybody on the first day of
their PhD or masters should get an email
saying this is what you can do with your
data this is what you can't do with your
data because we see somebody mentioned
it before we see two peaks in the people
who use picture we see undergrads who
grew up with the internet sorry post
grads who grew up the internet and know
how to control the access and the
privacy controls on on websites and we
see tenured professors who are like this
is how it should be done let's just do
it let's just throw it all out there and
who cares what happens where's the
postdocs are the ones who are terrified
and they will only do things if they are
told to explicitly do it and it will
help their career so people need to be
educated and so for all the people at
institutions here please tell all your
researchers thanks thank you thank you
providing commentary a virtual you can
be gig you can be guaranteed that the
u.s. does the right thing after they
tried everything else first so thank you
all my name is dennis tan enema english
professor and it might be wondering what
I'm doing here and then what what I'll
do is I'll first start with an anecdote
then I'll try to leave a thread between
these three talks and then I'll talk
about what I think is the elephant in
the room it's not elsevier guys don't
worry but we have to make finally a
little bit but all right so anecdote
thread elephant that's the plan so so
the anecdote first is that we right now
me and my students and some other
colleagues are launching kind of a
humanity space lab and it's a database
lab and it's about piracy and the impact
of piracy and literary culture and we
are dealing with data in the English
department in the history department we
have about 12 terabytes of full text
data we have metadata we have XML data
dumps we have sales data this kind of
stuff so and we have in the humanities
we don't really have a culture of
sharing data of keeping data except for
of course the traditional culture the
library the journal and so on so so the
first thing we did and I actually did
this yesterday I'm not listen this is
very timely i SAT with my students and
said what's what's what is our platform
what what how are we going to set up
this environment so and platform it's
the the word that was used here platform
and I'm thinking what is a platform what
exactly is a platform for sharing
discovering impact and so on and I'm
kind I just wrote a bunch of kind of key
words here so platforms there they
involve some expertise they involve they
involve certain practices editorial
practices sharing practices there are
licensing schemas as you said there's
architecture there's norms as you said
institution trust training as as Mark
said
there is a architecture infrastructure
right that's all goes into the platform
right so so as we look out there
actually let me make an aside we all
agree that sharing discovering impact
that's all good and and I think very few
people say no to open access and no to
open source and free culture this kind
of stuff but okay that's fine but as I
look out there and that's me and my
students and my colleagues we look out
there we see a great proliferation of
platforms I mean just look in front of
me here go there is a UC three that
wants us to keep our data with them web
archiving service says that they're a
good platform sigh Val says come with us
fig share right and they're all and I
asked you this before the panel I said
are you are you guys in competition with
each other do you view yourself as kind
of and remark said no which is true I'm
sure I'm sure everybody here can explain
their own little niche but looking at
this whole ecosystem from the outside it
is a very confusing ecosystem right so
on the one hand you see this great you
see these platforms that are much more
transparent than the whole system
they're much more accessible right there
there's less friction they look better
they feel better right there they have
the right spirit but on the other hand
you have this great fragmentation right
it is difficult to train our students
our faculty in using new platforms there
is actually a lot of friction to getting
a whole discipline moving in that
direction we see incompatibility will
should I post my data and all of the
above just to be kind of just to
advertise or is it going to be
compatible is it going to be stable
enough with will in two years they'll be
even more and kind of better-looking
platforms and more accessible platforms
we don't know so the stability is also a
problem so that's what that's kind of my
little provocation that I think is the
tension in the room that's the elephant
in the room
and I would love to hear the responses
your responses on this and maybe our
panelists responses on this problem
thank you excellent well let's take some
time for comments from from the panel
and then we'll turn to audience
questions I have a comment on diversity
of offerings and marketplace you don't
have an an iphone so but something
similar so did you read the 200 page
manual for that but this yes I wasn't
asking you i was asking the first data
last time you rented a car at the
airport did you really take the whole
engine apart to make sure all the screws
are there and reassemble the whole day
so the point is we have we have over
years established certain methodologies
right the early cars you were rich you
actually hired a driver who could fix
the thing on the way while it was
breaking down right you actually had a
driver because you were a rich person he
wouldn't drive that thing yourself grid
computing for a long time was like that
you hire somebody that drives the grid
for you and somebody conducts this
experiment we have moved into an age
where most people are not willing to put
up with that so I started using Dropbox
for example some two years ago whenever
it roughly came about three years ago it
changed how I do things I never read a
manual so unless it becomes intuitive
and it bends it embeds itself in our
day-to-day work flow we're doing
something wrong because we all are busy
and we have enough stuff to do and the
time to learn something new is probably
between two and three a.m. that's it
right and this is this you can add this
to the list of qualities of a planet
intuitive is the word easy-to-use
adaptable because these all of these
technologies are going to
be in a steady state of change for the
rest of our lives and as we're hit with
new opportunities new needs new demands
we have two phase into them very very
graceful so I am so that's I think
that's that's too nice so for me
platforms also they don't allow you to
escape so for example I did not change
to Android for a long time because all
my contacts were on my old nokia and now
all my contacts are with google it is
very expensive for me to switch to
another home it's also that for me they
yeah there's an inertia and platform so
it is difficult for me to see how in
this environment of fragmentation how
you know platforms there by the
protocols and norms there they work best
when there's one platform right when we
are on Facebook that's what that's when
we can do it we go someplace else yeah
so that's what I don't get what's this
different the kind of the final state
here there must be either huge
integration or just a kind of whittling
of the market until there's kind of a
clear clear or several winners or
several alternative and I think that
will happen the reason I said no when
you said do I count all these different
places as competitors is because at the
moment there's so much data that there's
enough data to go around all of these
places you know still we're just at the
tip of the iceberg but in terms of on
both of these points you know we all the
public data is backed up in on fig shays
backed up in clocks which is another
great in organization and that stands
for controlled lakhs and lakhs is lots
of copies keep stuff safe and that is
true and there might be some redundancy
in this but there's things like sword
app where you can push from one
repository to another repository and
we're very much of the idea that you if
you I didn't use my institutional
repository because it was clunky and if
you need to do a webinar to use
something I'm never going to use it if i
needed a webinar to use facebook oh and
use facebook now but um so it has to be
intuitive so if you can get that
intuitiveness on one platform as you say
i've not say it's picture it could be
any one will be the one where people
start using it but that should then push
to your institutional repositories and
it should then make you know if
something belongs in genbank it should
automatically push to GenBank so we can
do this the technology exists
and I think that is the way to go
forward well good barring any other
quick comments I think it's important
for us to turn to the audience with
questions and I'm not sure Kathryn you
want to manage the big question she'll
be coming around with a microphone here
and will sweep across the room my name
is Daniel kelter from elsevier research
is a global enterprise and I think open
data and open access really assume a
level of a level of reciprocity and we
know there are high trust and low trust
societies that whole different values so
my question is particularly to Micah but
can the panel comment on the cultural
kind of impacts of things like high
levels of trust or low levels of trust
and willingness to contribute to open
data etc well trust high levels of trust
and low levels of trust are generally
not across the board it's trust in whom
for what and one of the one of the
interesting things I find about open
data and open access in general is the
the proportions of benefits that that
has been that has fallen to relatively
low trust societies outside the US for
example we're one of the projects that I
briefly pointed at the the d VN ojs
project which is creating a a workflow
for publishing replica open replication
data in conjunction with open access
articles ojs is a system for hosting
open access journals developed in Canada
and Stanford has 10,000 journals most of
these are in in other countries and and
I'm a big
a large proportion Africa because it
there's a low barrier to entry for it so
I think that the the impact there's even
more to gain in societies that and
countries that are more clothes than the
u.s.
we'll closed end result yes good list
catherine has so here comes microphone
we sat handed over here good afternoon
Richard win airy systems one of the
benefits of closed access systems is
that there's a feedback mechanism if a
product is sold and its successful
people pay more and their sustainability
if the product is no good then the money
stops in the product disappears and I
think part of the challenge with some of
your systems right now is there's not
that feedback mechanism and so I think
it would be useful to tell us how your
projects are funded and what will happen
in the longer term when that funding
stops so so let me respectfully disagree
that when you've seen forms of feedback
on at least two sites and we keep track
of usage people vote with their feet in
terms of what they use and what doesn't
get used that is being fed back to the
author authors have rankings authors can
earn currencies or concern values they
might be able to trade those values down
the line right now nanohub is funded
from the NSF it was started as an
infrastructure and research network
grant for ten years we turned it into a
national infrastructure and we got
funded for another five plus five years
just now so NSF sees value in it and yes
it's federal funding at the end of the
road in 10 years what I would love to
see in terms of sustainability is a nano
hub society in where people actually
participate they use the material they
contribute just like I Triple E or and
they don't mind spending fifty dollars a
hundred dollars a year to participate in
this organization because they derive
day-to-day benefit that's a dream okay
I'll give you that but but they have to
be ways of financial sustainability and
going to a market that actually pays for
these things
we can always just assume that some sort
of government socially beneficial or not
is going to pay for that but if you had
asked me 10 years ago or many people ten
years ago if I had listened to computer
scientists they would have discussed
till today what kind of data format we
need to use on how to this just
distribute we were more whether shut up
and do it kind of philosophy and
actually did it and then we can talk
about currencies or value systems right
so I don't sometimes it's try and then
apologize later son yes please please do
it for the webcast thank you I'd like to
follow up on that absolutely and it's
interesting to hear you say that
eventually you do see a commercial model
for nano hub I'd also like to hear from
fixture on the same point because it
could be non profit right it could be
self-sustaining it doesn't have to be
generating profits yeah but for example
the publishing done by the american
chemical society is nonprofit okay so
but it's not open access so or it's
mainly not open access so the question
is long term sustainability because in
the short term obviously things can be
funded with entrepreneurs venture
capital funding from agencies etc but in
the long term it's the sustainability of
the model that will make sure that those
data are there 10 years from now so just
to answer the fixture so don't you wanna
jump in before I say that no I'll drop
it out okay so just so
fig shares commercial company we are
looking for we are looking for
sustainability the way we do that at the
moment is to sell to publishers and to
sell to academic institutions the
examples I showed plus in fact of a
thousand research our customers of fig
share Peter in his earlier talk
mentioned you know he'd like to see what
happens with fig share what you know
will we be clothed putting up walls at
any stage we've already always
categorically said that it's free fat
individuals who want to make their
research outputs publicly available if
you make it publicly available it'll
always be publicly available if our
sustainability model doesn't work as I
say everything it's backed up in clocks
so those do is we'll always resolve to
the object that you have uploaded and
I'm just one extra point that I did her
at the beginning we did I I did look to
see whether to go through the a cadet
making an academic project was the way
to go forward with it and a welcome were
interested and we nearly went with them
until they said they had the perfect
grant but you needed five years postdoc
experience so it wasn't exactly perfect
you know they made you Jim for him odd
hoops but I'm so happy that we didn't
now for the reason that if you can't get
any more funding than that's kaput you
know it just goes yeah like good money
sure I I think you make a very good
point I was I was trained in a thinly
discuss what's at that time a thinly
disguised economics department so I
learned classical economic micro theory
and all the rest and one of the
beautiful things one of the most
beautiful things about private markets
is how they aggregate information price
is a signal value right and so with when
you're not selling things you're losing
this signal that's a very important
aspect the institutional design
consideration the problem with that is
that works in markets when goods are
private right when when goods are
excludable when they get used up the
theories that otherwise they're not such
a signal of value there a signal of
value to particular people
who are above us particular threshold
but not they don't capture all of the
potential value right so open access
become is an imperfect has imperfect
signals of value but the markets have
imperfect signals of value for these
goods as well right and in the projects
that I've been involved with they have
been almost always italy funded by a
mixture of a volunteer effort which is
how academia works in part and and
federal or foundation funding with the
idea that we would get institutions
addicted to them that the institution's
research institutions would find these
things to be so useful that they would
continue using them and that's in fact
what's what's happened and you can you
know Harvard has taken over for example
the dataverse network which as part of
their their library service and you can
think of Harvard at the University but
you can also think of it as a large head
hedge fund with a a smaller research
group attached to it you know so and
it's not clear as I said there are many
you know it's not clear what the future
of the universities are but Harvard made
there they got their competitive
advantage by introducing merit-based
tenure after in the 50s after World War
two GI Bill and now universities are
looking to not only capture the best
faculty but to capture the best students
through massive open online courses to
capture the world's best learners and
employ them and the and they and the
organizations that do that are going to
have a huge competitive advantage and a
lot of that requires that the students
be able to access this material so there
is a there's a huge institutional
interest in creating a body of
intellectual content that is X openly
accessible and then capturing the best
of the best for your research Enterprise
Catherine got another question and then
you tell us to how we're doing on time
hi Holly Falk krasinski also from
elsevier and we're not trying to grab
questions but we noticed there was a
gender imbalance of asking questions so
I'm representing the women at elsevier
with this one okay so we have a question
it could be for this panel but it could
be for any of the panelists that came
before and that's a question of bad
behavior I'm a little bit of a cynic and
and I I readily shared I spent the last
15 years in at Northwestern University
in academia started a non-profit worked
at my synagogue that was a non-profit
got management training and nonprofit
and then just moved elsevier so I like
nonprofit and I like sharing until the
day that you google your google search
shows up some piece of work that you did
that somebody else is claiming is their
own with absolutely no attribution to
you to your institution to your work no
additive value to your reputation so
what I haven't heard in any of the panel
is really is how we deal with bad
behavior we're making the assumption
that to test reproducibility and the
validity of data means that the people
who will come after you will be as
ethical and will not engage in
misconduct and what they report on will
also be good information but we have no
way to guarantee that and so I'd like to
understand more about how the open
environment though also helps to protect
the individuals who in our academic
schemas rely on being recognized for
individual accomplishments and are
rewarded in a very stringent structure
that when you don't get promoted and
tenured you lose your job it's very
finite it's you know I mean it's severe
and so we need to think about that and I
think it gets to your point of the
postdocs they're trying very hard at
this point to to move from from the
trainee to independent and they have to
prove their independence their
individual self worth and any risk to
that being taken away even a little bit
is severe to their professional
development and I just haven't heard a
cure or even a guard for that I have a
one-liner answer but you plagiarize you
lose your job yes you do
plagiarize my sudden losers well did you
catch him that they go to the yes Wow
yes yes cuz you might guess for me i'm
not good at just sitting by and letting
things go either yes so no those
consequences didn't happen in fact i was
just going to say that we deal with it
the exact same way that Elsa field deals
with it if someone was we have you know
the riddle there is no solution to this
at the moment we're you know a member of
coke which is publication ethics we have
standard take down procedures but
there's no solution until this happens
you know if I was to go and copy
someones elsevier paper and publish it
somewhere else as my own how are you
going to track that so at the moment I
don't think there is a solution I don't
know if it's a big enough problem for
people to throw in you know all of this
that effort into it but obviously if
you've been stung by it then it's the
most important thing in the world so
yeah I I don't know the answers that
maybe someone else tell ya it's very
important can I jump in and this one is
is so all married based systems can be
exploited including traditional ones we
know from traditional publishing there's
plagiarism there is data made up data
going on all the time and the best cure
for that so far that I think we've seen
is transparency when there are new
practices that encourage scientists and
humanists to share their data the
original data to publish code along with
the data that transparency is what cures
cures I think those kind of abuses and
what is nice in this new platform many
of these new platforms are more
transparent same same thing can be said
about the merit-based system if tenure
process was more transparent I think it
would also be healthier it is trent is
transparency a cure or does it only get
you to where you are already when you
ask the question does it only get you to
the point where you can find it is it
really a cure it stops a different
problem so it stops people making up
data if you demand to see the data
that's why i said that paper that you
click the graph and see the data behind
it i love because i was always in
journal clubs thinking why have they
displayed the data like this when all
their other graphs they've used the
different axes and it's because they're
fiddling the data to get a significant
result which is obvious but if you have
that transparency then you overcome that
problem it's a completely separate issue
to the plagiarism it's well sometimes
sometimes not sometimes it's a cure if
you in if you're in a environment where
you typically publish preprints you put
your working drafts on archive you share
your data initially it's very hard to
then take over at the time of
publication say i have somebody else
claim to do that work because you have a
record of you have a record prior to
that work being worth of being taken
over right but i'll have to go back to
two transfers loss right technology
these are huge changes in information
technology technology is neither good
nor bad neither is it neutral right it
changes the game right it means if you
put your stuff out if you do open lab
science you're much less likely to be
plagiarized but somebody could get the
jump on the next step right if you kept
all your research clustered right maybe
nobody's going to grab it but you still
have the you know the the first the
first discover problem right and and so
you could be working for years and
nobody plagiarizes you but if you don't
publish first it's all for naught so
there are different it's a different
system and it has its advantage of
various ways yeah and I would just say
don't be discouraged you know I deal
with the plagiarism question I deal with
the copyright infringement question all
the time they get mixed up they're not
the same but they're closed they're akin
to one another but I deal with them all
the time
and and you know the questions the
conversation often boils down to this
yeah you have rights but there's not
much you can do about them the the and
so so so part it's part part of the
challenge as we as we have already moved
into into this digital environment our
content by one means or another will be
out there and I get the question all
times so how can I control it make sure
somebody doesn't misuse it and the
answer is largely you can't and so it's
so so some misuse in inappropriate use
is is honestly it's part of the cost of
the inevitability of where technology
has taken us another example maybe
trivializing it there's 14,000 people
dying in the United States from car
accidents I don't think we're going to
outlaw cars and streets anytime soon so
I mean there is a sort of a balance and
I hear CC waving with a question over
here and this will be our last question
um i'm lisa rose miles science librarian
at Seton Hall but I used to be a
behavioral ecologist in my past life and
this is back to this idea of long-term
sustainability I'm thinking gee I have a
ton of data from my graduate work like
reams and reams and means of it which I
would happily make available the lord
knows why anybody would want it the
thing is it was coded in a computer
program that a friend of mine wrote just
for me downloaded a debased uploaded to
SPSS like version 2 I don't think it's
usable anymore in a similar vein I had a
question at the reference desk the other
night somebody who had some ancient data
from the 60s from a government site that
was I couldn't even figure out what it
was I mean I think it was just basically
in binary code so my question is in
terms of this long-term sustainability
we have all this wonderful stuff that we
put in repositories but things change
very rapidly something that's current
today I mean is there any guarantee that
an excel file i put in today you'd be
able to read five years later
and who would do all the continual
upgrading to new versions that's a big
cost so we're looking at this with
regards to one way you can do it is if
you make if you convert everything to an
open data standard format then the idea
is that you could say okay so if you if
it's an excel file you can convert it on
the fly so you should be able to
download it as a CSV or something like
that we haven't got this implemented yet
but it's something we're doing but is
because there is such a sheer volume of
files we can't we might not be able to
save things going backwards but you know
this is another education thing people
should be educated to put the files in a
non proprietary format maybe which if
you use SPSS maybe and I'll going to but
yeah okay and I'm afraid our time is up
and and I want to give a run of applause
for a great panel and thank you